dr. Burton DeLong is the head of
emergency services in a hospital in the
small town of doula in northern France
with limited resources staff have
adapted the hospital to treat
coronavirus patients we've used plastic
sheeting to create separate spaces to
reduce the risk of infections more than
20,000 people have died in France since
the start of the health crisis the death
toll rises each day but the number of
patients and intensive care is slowly
diminishing the French government says
from May 11th it loosened the strict
lockdown but dr. Delorme says it will be
a while until this hospital is back to
normal the last months have been
exhausting in my department to doctors
and several nurses had coronavirus we've
had no visibility on when the crisis
will end or how long we'll have to work
like this because for us D confinement
doesn't mean the end of the coronavirus
emergency the French government hasn't
provided details of its D confinement
plan those are expected at the end of
April nevertheless some businesses are
getting ready managers at this car
factory have put in place protective
measures for workers in case production
is permitted to resume staff will have
their temperature taken and if it's too
high they will not be allowed on to the
sites that do this thang until the
French government reveals its full D
confinement strategy many people in
France feel simply uncertain about their
futures they don't know when they're
going to be able to go back to work when
schools like this one will reopen or
when it will be possible to once again
walk in the streets freely without a
permit while some people are looking
forward to restrictions being eased
others are cautious and since it might
be a danger for the altie bird because
they might catch the virus it's possible
to do but only people wear masks and
with strict conditions the government
says that life in France after the
lockdown will not be the same as before
and for
months to come people will have to take
precautions until away is found to
control or stop the spread of
coronavirus in doula hospital staff know
that the crisis is far from over
Natasha Butler al-jazeera mamuro France